há um tempo atrás me ligaram
era uma das coordenadoras deixe evento
nessa ligação ela me convidou para estar
aqui
ao me contar isso minha barriga mexeu
minha garganta secou e nessa conversa eu
aceitei prontamente fiquei muito honrado
por estar aqui neste momento ela me
perguntou também jonas
qual é a profissão que eu comunico a
todos na divulgação do evento e eu disse
ela bom eu sou um comunicador e ao me
comunicar e ajuda as pessoas a falarem
com mais poder e espontaneidade com mais
segurança
naquele momento ela me disse mas
comunicador não é uma profissão no
brasil então eu disse eu sou cook county
também não é uma profissão regulamentada
no brasil então eu lembrei de uma das
três conversas que eu tive com o meu pai
que foram cruciais na minha vida quando
eu estava no colegial desde o colegial
eu finalizei o colegial e eu conversei
com o meu pai eu falei 'pai eu tento
fazer uma faculdade que faculdade o que
eu faço meu pai totalmente analítico
olhou para o mercado analisou as nossa
cidade e disse jonas
nunca vi um farmacêutico ficar
desempregado ou passar fome aqui
farmácia
e eu fui lá entre a farmácia e farmácia
me formei farmacêutico só que não podia
responder ela que eu era farmacêutico
porque não tava mais atuando como
farmacêutico
então disse que quer saber fala pra
galera do ted fiz do ted ex tinham sim
sou um comunicador e eu ajuda as pessoas
a se comunicarem com mais confiança com
mais entusiasmo a serem autênticas nesse
mundo e é por isso que hoje eu vou falar
pra vocês sobre o poder da comunicação
eu sempre me perguntei sempre me
perguntei jonas como que as pessoas se
conectam como que barack obama conversa
como que os grandes líderes a apple
entrega seu conteúdo
então eu parei para analisar e perceber
que tinha um padrão ao analisar esse
padrão eu percebi que essas pessoas se
distanciavam das outras porque ela
seguir um método e esse método mudou
totalmente a minha maneira de me
comunicar
mudou totalmente a minha forma de
encarar o mundo e é por isso que eu
chamo de efeito rodo o efeito o rodo na
comunicação me tornou consciente porque
atualmente a grande maioria das pessoas
se comunica do presente e leva as
pessoas para o futuro seja esse futuro
111 uma venda seja estrutura uma
inspiração que toca o coração dessas
pessoas mas sempre assim nos comunicamos
hoje aqui eu te convido para fazer algo
nesse futuro e ao me comunicar dessa
forma muitas vezes eu não me conecto com
as pessoas e por que eu chamo de efeito
o outro porque os grandes líderes as
grandes organizações elas adicionam algo
a mais nessa comunicação elas adicionam
um passado comum elas vêm do passado e
mostram que esse passado o porque elas
são as pessoas certas a levarem as
pessoas para o presente do presente
levares elas para o futuro
naquele momento eu percebi essa ideia eu
falei o mundo inteiro precisa saber
disso eu preciso contar para o mundo
inteiro e como eu vou chamar essa idéia
eu vou chamar ela de efeito
tudo porque quando você vai limpar a sua
casa você joga aquela água no chão
aquela água se dispersa e daí o que você
faz você vai lá pega o rodo e começa a
buscar água mais próxima
começa a buscar aquela mais distante e
busca lá no cantinho para depois poder
escoar essa água e é essa o método da
maneira que as pessoas utilizam para se
conectar que as grandes organizações que
os grandes palestrantes dos grandes
líderes utilizam para se conectar
eles começam um passado comum nesse
passado comum eles contam fatos que
conectam eles com o público ao conectar
eles com o público eles trazem eles para
o presente e do presente eles convidem
eles pra fazer essa função no futuro
seja ela mais uma vez uma venda seja ela
uma inspiração seja algo que toca o
coração porque é conexão que importa é
por causa da conexão que nós estamos
aqui hoje é por causa da conexão que
milhares de pessoas se sentem
confortáveis em comprar algo da apple a
apple se ela fosse utilizar um método
normal o tradicional de comunicação ela
ia falar da seguinte maneira
olha eu sou uma fábrica de computadores
eu fabrico ao extraordinário eu fabrico
algo tecnológico e você com certeza vai
querer comprar o no entanto como o que a
apple faça a sua comunicação ela e usa a
idéia do efeito rodou na comunicação
porque ela primeiro começa falando assim
bom nós surgimos da idéia do nosso
fundador steve jobs
junto com um amigo na garagem de uma
casa versa garagem da casa que ele fez
ele foi lá e conversou com o amigo
montou essa ideia começou a projetar a
entregar essa idéia começou a entregar
esse conteúdo e começou a esculpir a
apple lá dentro
detalhe o tipo de óbito era filho de um
casal americano tradicional numa garagem
e eu contar essa história do passado da
época a apple mostra no presente o
porquê ela empresa habilitada a levar
você para o futuro por meio dos seus
equipamentos por meio dos seus produtos
isso é literalmente uma consciência que
a apple cria gente e ela disse vocês
estão conectados comigo e é por isso que
eu falo para vocês o seguinte quando
você for contratar alguém se você ele
literalmente só falará single de
contrato
você vai fazer isso no futuro o que
acontece
a pessoa vai trabalhar literalmente para
o seu dinheiro vai trabalhar por aquele
salário de qualquer proposta qualquer
coisa
rompi é uma ligação fraca no entanto
quando você conta a história da empresa
porque ela foi fundada com as quais
foram os objetivos ou porque você
trabalha está contratando aquela pessoa
que acontece
ela começa a entender o porquê ela faz
parte daquilo e por que ela executa
aquilo e ela primeiro conta pra ela
depois a conta para os colaboradores ao
redor dela depois as contas dos clientes
e principalmente para os familiares dela
ela quanto porque ela trabalha pra você
é literalmente no nosso consciente
quando nos conectamos lembro muito bem
para o trabalho quando eu olhei para o
meu pai e disse pai na nossa segunda
grande conversa porém pai eu quero ficar
18 meses sem trabalhar como farmacêutico
eu quero ir lá pra áfrica fazer trabalho
voluntário e meu pai todo analíticos
ético disse você vai largar sua
profissão sua carreira você vai pra onde
eu fui campeã na áfrica eu vou passar um
período na áfrica no malauí e ele mas
sua profissão e canaã e as doenças da
áfrica que vão fazer contigo meu pai
totalmente analítico naquele momento eu
disse pai senhor não percebeu né
quantas vezes você sai de casa à noite
junto com minha mãe para fazer trabalho
comunitário nessa cidade
quantas vezes pai você me deixou em casa
no domingo no sábado ou literalmente
milhões de m deixou sentado e do evento
porque você estava trabalhando na nossa
igreja pai
quantas vezes você no seu passado e
mostrou que esse era um caminho sim de
felicidade de entrega e hoje nesse
presente eu só peço pra você deixa eu
fazer isso no futuro
meu pai é aquele momento não teve que
fazer o que falar e só teve como
concordar
e aquele dia ele mudou a chave ele mudou
a consciência dele porque literalmente é
no nosso sistema límbico que a gente
percebe as coisas quando o meu pai no
começo pensava no neocórtex o nosso
sistema no nosso sistema cerebral ali
ele pensava racionalmente ele falava
jonas farmácia porque o farmacêutico
você vai ganhar dinheiro não vai morrer
aegypti depois ele começou a transportar
entender o sistema límbico eu comecei a
me conectar no sistema límbico do meu
pai
o sistema comportamental do ser humano e
ao se comunicar no passado como trazer o
ser humano presente e depois levar pro
futuro o ser humano é literalmente vai
começar a fazer assim é se você só come
conectar no presente e no futuro ele vai
falar assim nossa que bonito quanto
custa
qual é a especificação ele vai decidir
vai tomar uma decisão racional
no entanto quando você se conecta no
passado explicou por que você é
habilitado por que você está comum a ele
o que acontece
o cara olha o teu produto olha pra você
e diz assim olha eu sei que esse é que é
o melhor é muitas vezes a especificação
de ser melhor mas simplesmente eu sinto
que eu quero é esse
ele simplesmente senti ele simplesmente
vi
é por isso que centenas de milhares de
pessoas se sentirão confortável a votar
por barack obama
por que barack obama ao se candidatar
nos estados unidos o que ele fez ele
começou a contar a sua história ele
começou a mostrar que ele é filho de um
pai imigrante casado com uma americana
ele é um afro americano onde nasceu no
havaí e depois da família ainda se
separou e ele sim negro era uma pessoa
que representaria aquela população no
presente daquela localidade daquele país
e ele sim tinha um passado em comum com
a grande maioria pra quê
para levantar a bandeira da igualdade
social para ser o representante
igualitário porque ele negro filho de
imigrantes se conectava com a população
e depois ainda de uma família que
separou ele sim tinha um passado comum
com a grande maioria dos americanos
eu lembro
claramente da terceira e grande conversa
que eu tive com meu pai quando eu olhei
liguei pro meu pai
olhei pro celular e falei agora o
momento tenho que conversar com o meu
pai
algo que vai mudar a minha vida liguei
pro meu pai disse pai eu quero largar a
minha profissão de farmacêutico meu pai
naquele momento eu pensei exatamente que
ele a racionalizar dizer sobre dinheiro
dizer sobre carreira dizer sobretudo meu
pai literalmente falou assim jonas
negócio da minha infância quando eu
estava capinando na roça junto com o seu
avô
o sol era quente queimava a minha nuca a
minhas costas doíam e eu era jovem ainda
eu olhei pro seu avô e disse pai eu não
quero mais fazer isso eu quero algo
diferente pra mim ea qaida jonas o teu
avô disse algo pra mim disse o filho se
é isso que você quer
busque o seu caminho que seu pai sempre
estar aqui pra te apoiar
e hoje jonas chegou a minha vez e dizer
pra você
se é isso que você quer
se o teu caminho que você sim e eu
sempre estarei aqui pra te apoiar
e você sim seguirá o caminho que você
desejar
o ted é sobre idéias sobre
compartilhamento
naquele momento o meu pai contou sua
história o seu passado como ele se
conectar no meu presente disse filho
siga para o futuro por meio do poder da
comunicação ele usou a idéia do efeito
rodo para se conectar comigo e toda vez
que eu penso e passa por momentos
difíceis eu lembro sim no qual está aqui
para me apoiar
eu digo pra vocês muitas vezes você vai
pensar que você não quer ser um obama
mas isso aqui é você hoje no
conhecimento eu pergunto quantas
milhares de pessoas possui um pouquinho
menos de conhecimento que você
você pode sim utilizar o seu passado
como para elevá las ao seu nível
então utilize o seu passado comum para
inspirar as pessoas no presente e
levá-las para um futuro melhor porque
hoje nós podemos construir esse presente
por meio da nossa conexão o consciente
das pessoas
eu acredito fielmente que quando
compartilhamos somamos e podemos juntos
impactar a vida de muitos
então bora pra cima do palco das nossas
vidas
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]